alright girl step boy it's my mom
I guess ok yeah my mom was pretty good
raising us I just remember being
molested by my brother yeah yeah I guess
he was 13 years going to privily if I
will recall and I was I'm like what 3
years younger than him so was about 19
years old I recall and I guess I try to
blank it out all these years I went
through my mom and her phone's auto body
but you know when he had a baby I
reacted I you know reacted out with my
uncle messy you know touching us because
it was six sisters and one brother I
guess that's all I could remember I mean
it was pretty good you know my desk
holders a lot I was one of those when
they say not to do it I did it
he was around for a while but he was an
alcoholic so he was more less out you
know like I was a pitcher you know he
was even paralyzed for a while I
remember it was trying to be terrible
and my mom got tired of him you know so
he was around but you're not really it
was mom they raised us I gave my mom all
the credit I don't know I wrote young I
remember getting hooked on cocaine at 15
but already like about fifth or sixth
grade which I don't know how old I was
then I was waiting around to older
people hypes PCP smokers you know I was
just I like the crazy lifestyle my mom
never used and my dad was an alcoholic
so I don't know where I went wrong my
uncle's all my uncles and aunts are
getting traded each other you know but I
just chose that life yeah I'm from
permitir flats I'm from flats
thankfully it real heavy I got in young
I got in I thinking in the sixth grade
yeah I know fifth sixth grade then I
started to eat cocaine the cocaine's
what I had a baby ahead of my first
daughter and my mom took her because of
me you know running in and out of the
house and I don't blame her I know just
smoking I remembered Ernie had a
prostitute right away you know so he
taught me how to use this you know be in
the streets you know that it was easy
money better than robbing and hurting
people so I did that and it was just
easy money
real easy money which it was you know
you got your fellow killers out there
you got your people that beat you up and
rape you and you have a hard life
I remember going through a lot against
taxing you you know trying to get your
money and just just getting high living
a crazy life it really didn't bother me
I was like one of those crazy people
yes when I was young I was in everything
as Cesar Chavez always liked I think I
was about 20 21 around somewhere around
there they were telling us get off the
street Wow
I remember going with him
he pulled out a big machete my neck and
raped me but the whole time he was
raping me out I have such a fun mouth I
was like it you take too small you know
I got cake I can't feel it wasn't my
[ __ ] big I was being a real smartass I
couldn't I was just testing on my own
testing people I don't know why yes you
could tell me shut up [ __ ] I just kept
just testing on the tested oh man when
he was doing it's funny and then it's
not because my I'm still alive
I remember him getting my a spicy man
from here to here
three women end up missing at that point
when this happened to me I don't know
what year it is I can't tell you stuff
like that but I was about 20 21 well he
was done I remember said get the [ __ ] up
the cargo but no you take me back to he
took me
oh I was just worried those crazy people
I mean yes I was I did this when I was
young and then I could turn another
incident I was pregnant in a car which I
have marks I have lot of scars on me
which I could tell us adheres to here
but I am I remember being in there and
it was so embarrassing because getting
morning and I was just I was given the
head he was but was going towards away
sure all that a paranoid I'd you know
crazy cocaine that's the only thing ever
did I tried all the drugs I drink I
smoke just the cocaine and he paid me
and when he was done I just felt
something weird so I looked at him had a
knife to my throat give me back the
money [ __ ] and I was like oh I don't
know hey everything I went through you
want this money back it's not gonna work
out so I grabbed the knife and I pulled
it out and I remember he was hitting me
which look I don't feel nothing you know
just so I'm like try to get it yes oh
the wrong [ __ ] give me the [ __ ]
weapon when he never said money having a
pocketknife and he swag got me again
which I don't feel nothing in the head
so you know then I'm just
and he looked like [ __ ] and I said
you know don't ever come over here doing
that to us and I end up but he my whole
enum I'm so tired I remember a lady
passing I said I'm gonna take this she
showed up your ass or more twisted and
he kept talking my hair but I was ex
down doing like I feel nothing
so if you know what are you doing but
it's freaked them out more so stay off
my glass but I wouldn't go tonight when
I finally got off my mercy like [ __ ] you
know and I have blood all over my hand
it's praying I'm wrapping up my baby and
but just isn't it like I wanted to try
one after another I just didn't care I
was like a walking dead walking zombie
people look at me that what you said I
don't know when I got part of the street
I've been through hell in that big time
then when I came just there's stories I
could go on and on just believe me my
kids already have three white darling
Jessica no my mom Adam I try to take her
my stomach when he was in the street for
a while homeless would be mine or was it
again system tight but they love me I
know my kids I have a good relationship
with them and sometimes you know they
pick up they're mad at mom and they know
about my life they never approve of it
but they're like [ __ ] mom hustles you
know I never ask nobody for [ __ ] I take
care of my stuff you know when I him
don't tell I lost my house Abama gave me
a house have a beautiful people to get
me Facebook a lot I am I lost it I came
down to ask it all just so hard as so
difficult I doubt her my gosh that
recently like that skin graft I was in
the hospital for a whole month they try
to rob me and I woulda cause money I
figured I worked hard for it I'm not
gonna give it to anybody you know I
don't bother of rob I don't do nothing I
carry myself or respectfully furthermore
you nice them
I'll slow down here when somebody
finally told me they stabbed me here so
they got me right by the heart that took
a part of me that changed me from being
a nice person now I have like a wallop
which always had Wells Atlit more more
and um cool a lot of people down here
Norman I didn't they all attacked me
here I'll try to break me recently and
then we'll tele I have a bug here they
bashed my face into the radiator try to
crack your neck and I'm still stuck deep
I'm still standing somebody just sucked
me cuz they're high
you know they hit me in the face but I'm
just one of those like whoa tell me why
did what did I do now check myself I got
ya I walk up to them stupid crack kills
a brain dude I walk right up to it he
hit me so hard that I actually felt
stars cuz I don't feel nothing remember
I saw heart the boy today I don't know
what's gonna happen to me I don't know
what's gonna be calling me I'm trying to
get into a program just you know like
just I know there's different things out
there I got seven kids my grandkids and
I want something better you know my 20s
was in prison clothes for 16 years
you name it I done it like I have
man which wasn't me I have murder cases
187 is I have a I have more of this
stuff that and all I did was prostitute
it somewhere it's more correction so my
ass but I have pain around places won't
please guns you know like I have bad
charges but just being around bad people
I guess you get caught up you know but
then I have bad about our security
recently which it wasn't me you know she
started it but just a normal person kind
of live in the streets
I just got out of detox but I would just
been there day this is a way look I lost
67 pounds I'm the skinny one oh yes a
lot of people tell me to get on a skid
row you know just oh my kids just got
their life together
they just got Section eight he just got
nine grandkids I don't want to [ __ ]
their life up I didn't you know the
damage as it is so I tried to do this on
my own
but I know my family has my back you
know I just hope they make it out of
life my mom's around my dad's around
- Woody's living his life sold already
not reasonably I hope soon on June I
lost a little boy behind a murder case
angel June 8
I've met him for the first time came
back into my life I came back then I
seen him I always have faith I wasn't
obscene I'm again and I did so good
things are happening and bad things
we're just trying to hold on try to hang
in there best I can